finally here at noon this weekend  henderson international school is  honoring the world's greatest detectives  with a production of young sherlock the  very first performance is today  there'll be another one planned for  tomorrow lots of incredible talented  students here in the valley including  the group that has joined us today in  the studio i'd like to give a shout out  to the best middle school students we've  got sixth seventh and eighth graders  waving high they're taking a tour  learning all about what it takes to do  media work and anchoring and producing  and writing and we are so happy that  they are here we love having you guys in  the studio one more wave  yay  folks at home thank you so much for  joining us today at noon we hope you  have a happy cinco de mayo  [Music]